what's going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch ourselves the season
two premiere of gravity falls the last
few episodes have been phenomenal i hear
season two is just
even
better so if you can leave a like be
very much appreciated also you know
full-length watch along as we sync up
with the time code for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page check
out everything we've got to offer over
there and if you could subscribe and
click that notification bell that'd also
be very much appreciated and then boyza
prepper thanks for helping us edit this
down let's do this
[Music]
gideon
see there there it is again we haven't
seen readings like this for 30 years run
offerman from deep space an enemy weapon
site just as i suspected
gentlemen we're going to gravity falls
oh my god the town of hawkins is in
danger hopper no we're here to celebrate
the defeat of that skunk little gideon
boo everyone's saying something stupid
something stupid
we're doing a karaoke bonanza people
likes music enchantment
and an amazing karaoke performance
i would never agree to that ever too
late and what your name is on the list
it's happening oh god now that we have a
moment i've been meaning to ask you for
my journal back you mean this whole
thing it was so boring i couldn't even
finish it
uh
you didn't see nothing
wait you're just gonna give it to me
just like that what else do you want a
kiss on the cheek i gotta go what
i wouldn't mind the crystal tree not
gonna happen sauce uncle stan there's
something huge going on right under our
noses and it's time we stop goofing
around and get to the bottom of it bro
you've looked at that thing like a
bazillion times there's nothing left to
discover half the pages are blank
remember
nah there's secrets within don't worry
dipper lord mystery ham is on the case
well i played by my old rules what-what
get him to talk
we're here from the government wait what
government vehicle
this is agent trigger we're here to
investigate reports of mysterious
activity in this town activity you gotta
be joking i assure you i am not i was
born with a rare disorder that makes me
physically incapable of experiencing
humor
now if you'll excuse us we're conducting
an investigation investigation
wait wait did you guys say you're
investigating the mysteries of this town
that information is classified but yes
i believe there's a conspiracy of
paranormal origin all connected to this
town are you kidding me i'm
investigating the exact same thing i
found this journal in the woods
if we work together we could crack the
case if you have evidence of these
claims we should talk
oh no
please please come in i have so much to
show you oh no
we have other spots to investigate we'll
be on our way i'm confiscating this for
evidence smart move uh-huh i'm
confiscating that card now how's about
you go be a normal kid uncle stan you
don't understand and don't go talking to
those agents i just need a chance to
show those agents my book the only book
you'll need tonight is right here
i said journey you say okay carrie
carrie
carrie
i could do this all day
carrie
[Laughter]
this voice singing trust me uncle dan
karaoke isn't about sounding good it's
about sounding terrible together yeah
by going to stan's room i could get in
so much trouble
yeah you're probably right that's what
makes it fun dummy
man i can't wait to smash that influence
oh
oh my gosh oh my gosh mabel is that a
boombox sweater see for yourself poke
go i want take off your shirt and make
it a rave i'll do anything for your
approval
oh come on i promise i won't send it to
anyone
i'll keep an eye out for stan you go
rustle through his weird old man bid
oh that's probably really grosser where
did you hide that card
nothing
gold chase
fully clothed women magazine
yes
i got it i have that journal i wanted to
show you and you're certain this journal
will help our case i'm a hundred percent
positive we're on our way
whoa
sorry dipper i got distracted oh no your
dumb obsession is gonna get us all in
trouble one of these days now go enjoy
the rest of the party cause when it's
over you're grounded what no no it's
real i swear you should send it to the
lab
am i saying that right your uncle was
right about that overactive imagination
we've got paperwork to do kid no tap
into the mainframe pouring paper first
objects spells listen uh uh corpus
leviticus uh no
mondovicium
their desperation is going to get us in
a lot of trouble
yeah
what have you done
[Music]
oh my god this spooky journal 100 real
now can we work together mother of all
that is holy what do we do it's just one
zombie trust me i see stuff like this
all the time
i love the green glow dude we've been
chasing the paranormal for years but
we've never seen anything like this
before get down
oh no
oh
[Music]
what's the one thing i asked you not to
do tonight raise the dead
sorry what sucker
send all don't panic maybe they're just
a really ugly flash mob
with all the horror movies i've seen i
know literally everything there is to
know about how to avoid zombies
yep
ah yeah
no
it's cannon now soos is dead the golf
cart
come on
that's a bummer good news for me though
sorry dude i just really want those
brains
[Music]
cool nice party zombies
darn kid he has no idea what he's
messing with
ah i got too much on my mind to worry
about those kids right now all right
let's see
oh man
hey dudes by the way i taught the
zombies how to get into the fuse box
among these dudes i'm like a genius
isn't there something in the journal
about defeating zombies no there's
nothing in here about weaknesses now
we're toast it's all my fault and no one
can save us
no
rise of grunkle stan
uncle stan i said now
all right you undead jerks you ready to
die twice yeah
stan of the dead monster who harasses my
family is me take that
hate
nice
[Music]
oh wow
everything hurts
i'm not an idiot dipper of course this
town is weird and the one thing i know
about that weirdness is that it's
dangerous
been lying about it to try to keep you
away from it to try to protect you from
it she did not prepare them for it
it looks like i didn't lie well enough
road to hell grunkle stan blowing in the
blacklight what all this time i thought
i knew all the journal secrets but
they're written in some kind of
invisible ink invisible ink this is it
zombies have a weakness previously
thought to be invincible their skulls
can be shattered by a perfect three
[Laughter]
i think you're both missing the obvious
solution
it's so stupid
[Music]
friday night we're gonna party till dawn
don't worry daddy i've got my favorite
dress on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like mars attacks exactly
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry about this guys i totally
ruined everything dipper are you kidding
me i got to sing karaoke with my two
favorite people in the world oh
as long as you promise me you'll only
use it for self-defense and not go
looking for trouble okay as long as you
promise me that you don't have any other
bombshell secrets about this town
promise liar
we have got a lot of zombie damage to
clean up
only moses wait it's gonna take a lot of
formaldehyde let's fix you up words
birds
sorry
dude the author secrets were hiding in
plain sight a whole new chapter of
mysteries to explore
so cool we need to bring in the big guns
but they'll never believe us then we'll
make them believe us this is the town
we've been searching for
[Music]
another zombie no no
oh no
oh okay it's just a sister what is that
a very ugly man
poor guy oh man
it's pretty wild to look back at where
this show was in the first few episodes
and then to go to where it's been lately
and especially up to now is really
enjoyable and everyone was right
everyone listen i don't expect you to
speak another word until you're doing it
all in your wrong
voice you hear me
i hear you loud and clear greg there you
go
you have to any commentary
must be
done in that voice this episode was like
a fine wooden desk i made by myself in
the woods i chopped the tree down with
my own bare hands and rubbed it against
my chest to fortify it that is a really
solid way of describing the emotional
intake of this episode for sure ron
now
uh yeah what are you doing
like a prostitute at sunday service
[Music]
um
yeah like looking at what this episode
was uh it just gave me so much a shift
in mood from what i was feeling prior to
hitting record today
and i found it it kind of inspired this
is the kind of tv i just really love
especially the way it's just been lately
has been the kind of tv i absolutely
just love to put on and get and wrapped
up in the imagination before it but
especially with the dumb grunkle stan
you know as much as i love like getting
the actual zombies that have them
actually look a little horrifying at
first like their eyes protruding out of
their skulls their brains exposed and
stuff
and how they are actually able to turn
they come in hordes like this was a real
zombie episode but also in a real 80s
fashion type of zombie uh episode is
really what they've done with the actual
narrative at hand and even setting that
up between the potential future conflict
of what's to come between dipper and
stan
of how um you know like they're both so
similar and that's ultimately what's
gonna lead to them
having probably another clash they've
already had that set up in the prior
season
based off the way how dipper feels stan
views him and now to get to this episode
where they're both doing the you know
having their cross fingers behind their
back showing that they don't mean what
they're promising
and they both want the same things and
if they can just learn to work together
but but also like michael's saying
getting to show that he actually cares
you know and i'm sure he's a badass that
was great what'd you think
i thought it was
unmatchably
incredible
i thought that they did a wonderful job
of taking this tale this herculean
allegorical
uh
uh folly
and making it into something intense
if i was a lesser man i would have
crapped myself by now
if i wasn't such a outdoorsman prepared
for situations such as these
what'd you think about the horror that
was in this episode love the horror i'm
a big horror fan
i grew up
my father chained me to the sofa and
made me watch night of the living dead
155 times
he told you that he had to be like uh
i really know how to be a survivor right
that's right
all my survivalism skills come from
there
and i thought this episode
i had flashbacks
not unlike a vietnam veteran survivor
would
i just thought of my father
and i thought about
all the crazy peril
that befell us as children my youth was
not a happy time
it was an intense coming of age that no
man should be subjected to but here i am
before you oh god well i'm glad that you
have a chance to finally be able to talk
about your real emotions on this matter
all the green light and the references
to various zombie motion pictures really
warmed my heart those are the kinds of
things that comfort me this kind of felt
like a thriller music it felt like it
reminded me of the thriller music video
in a lot of ways you know what i mean
thriller night
yeah keep your arms and hands inside
your doom buggy at all times
what was your favorite part of this
episode my favorite part was the guest
appearance by
nick
comrade yeah run off ron paul
[Laughter]
i liked that we have this prospect of a
continuous uh threat from the government
which i already feel like is very close
to our own lives
i already have massive distrust for the
government and that's what i want to see
in my children's programming
if i was to soften my boy child by
putting him in front of a cartoon i
would choose this one
it's kind of like stranger things but uh
more instead of a massive ensemble of
people it's like a more of a media
family you know
strange
things sure moderately strange things
moderately strange maybe for your life
yes
considering all you had to
i'm glad we agree all you had to go
through over the years
i was raised alone in the woods
i had to forget what happened to your
father
uh he left after a while and i had to
forage for myself from ages 8 to 18.
much like an animal much like an animal
then he came back and he said ron
i'm changing your name
you've done well you're not dead
you are my son
well i'm excited hopefully hopefully
nick offerman gets to appear here more
often in the series and then he he
stapled a beard to my face and that was
the last i saw of him
all right guys well this is some damn
good television
nick or ron or whatever waffle mountain
appreciate you being here any time hey
you know um we have some patrons on some
super sexy patrons so i'm sure are big
fans of you nick offerman
uh ron i've been waiting all day to
shout out some some fine people so why
don't you uh why don't we give a
specific patron today shout out to
someone
all right nick offerman pick your poison
um mikhail linden you got a very classic
name your name reminds me of like an old
candelabra
smelted in the 1600s with the finest
golden aura rescued from the spanish
crusades
it's the kind of thing i would display
in my home and i would flex in front of
and i would watch my rippling pecs warp
and change in the candle light much like
i imagined the classic gentleman of old
i bet you smell like mahogany and old
books mikhail and a fine glass of
whiskey i would like to drink you and
absorb your masculinity
and then we can go live off the grid
and start our own co-op
with our own mold of government
based on
machismo
and fine spirits
this is what humphrey's vocabulary
really funny gets utilized
kale you are you're a real gem you're a
peach you're a georgia peach you're a
georgia peach i picked with my own bare
hands squeezed down into jelly fermented
that jelly into a fine wine and served
to the queen at brunch
i would bench press you in a heartbeat
so we're good now we're good we're good
in the video now we are so good to end
them over the whole nickname
it's hard to keep it up
[Music]